we have been waiting for apple to bring
back touch id for years now and some
people even are saying that they will
not upgrade to a new iphone until apple
does so and it seems like apple is
listening because they're still filing
patents creating new technology with one
patent that was still updated just
yesterday but with that said even though
we have people like mark german and ming
chi ko saying that this is going to be
coming out a new under display
technology i believe that this will
never happen and we will never have
under display touch id on any iphone and
i'll explain exactly why believe it or
not apple has been working on this under
display tech since 2013
when they filed this patent that was
officially granted to them in
2015 and this shows an acoustic imaging
system that basically vibrates and
senses your fingerprint in order to
unlock it which is crazy now of course
this never came out but a couple years
after that they started making new
patents with new technology for the
iphone 10. this one used an optical
method with maybe a more accurate system
and they had this in the works for that
in order to be able to have a better
design without having that touch id
button but they ended up having issues
with not enough yield making this
possible with a company that they bought
a few years back and in the end we know
that face id ended up working out they
got it to work and then they no longer
had to rely on this or some of the
prototypes with the touch of the sensor
being on the back as basically plan c a
fail safe after that you would think
that apple would stop working on this
and just adopt face id completely but
they didn't they got another patent on
another technology that could make this
possible and use the display to read
your fingerprint and with that we kept
getting rumors of new iphones coming out
with this and i'll just fast forward and
say that iphone 13
was tested to have under display touch
id with five different analysts leaking
info with supply chain leaks showing
that this is what's gonna happen but of
course we know that it did not and the
iphone 13 did not adopt this technology
and the weird thing is these guys are
still talking about apple working on
under display touch id for the iphone 14
now but like i said i don't think that
this is going to happen and i believe
there are three reasons why it won't now
the first one is because this keeps
getting delayed and delayed the leaks
and the rumors and of course it is fun
but after you go from year to year and
it keeps getting pushed back it is just
annoying like i said uh first is gonna
come for the iphone 13 we had all the
info supply chain and then we see
updates for it coming for the iphone 14
and 2022 so that is this year but now we
have the latest release and it is
getting pushed back to 2023
and as we go on tech gets better
and this is where the second reason
comes in and that's the fact that face
id itself is getting better we know that
apple is updating the iphone design with
the hole punch camera that the
technology that allows face id to work
is getting smaller they're working on it
working underneath the display as well
and once they reach that do they need to
have an underneath the display face id
and touch id at the same time i don't
think so i think the final goal was to
achieve face id underneath the display
or at least not have that huge notch and
i don't think that they expected it to
take this long for underneath the
display touch id to properly
work and with that we also know that
apple wants to implement face id across
their lineup it's now included in ipads
and we also know that in the coming
years they are going to add it to more
ipads as well
and the same thing goes with macbooks
and potentially imacs we've had leaks
rumors uh and basically hardware info
that is going to be coming out we want
an imax we know that these new macbooks
have this notch even though the actual
camera portion of it is really tiny
apple left that extra space
for them to be able to put face id into
the macbook now i wish they did out of
the get-go maybe they're just waiting
for the smaller tech to be able to work
so that they won't need as much
thickness and it can work in the shape
but it's quite obvious that apple's
moving forward with that and of course
it's going to be great to have that with
your imax and ipads and everything else
now the final reason why i don't think
that the under display
touch id is ever going to come is
because of what they just released and
that is the latest version of ios they
release the ability to finally use face
id with a mask now this part of it just
blows my mind and this is the clear
reason that i think they're ditching
touch id
we've had this situation with a pandemic
and with masks for almost two years now
and people have been complaining this
about this this has been their biggest
complaint is just that so inconvenient
to use now sure if you think about it we
could give apple a pass for maybe a few
months maybe even half a year but it's
been almost two years and they just
released this software fix to be able to
allow you to do this now my thought is
they were working on this underneath the
display fingerprint tech we know there's
new patents that were filed in 2020 as
well to get the latest version to work
they're successful uh they have parts
it's super accurate now as well way more
accurate than before and we know that
even in january apple was working on
that for the iphone 13
that way they could capitalize on this
issue and give people another reason to
upgrade to the iphone 13. of course we
have the patents
but as we know it never happened and in
order for this to happen it not only has
to be able to work but it has to be
accurate enough in the fact that it's
going to be secure and also responsive
enough where it's going to work well
we know that with other under display
technologies for example we have one
plus that used that we have samsung
they had issues one plus we were able to
easily hack it in samsung's we did hack
but it was a lot more difficult but then
again samsung's it took a lot longer to
read it was less accurate there'd be a
lot of times it would fail and they've
been slowly improving on that technology
and for apple to adopt something it
needs to be good enough and it needs to
work out of the gate now of course after
that the rumors got shifted and the
reports and the parts that were designed
for this for example the iphone 14
and we had those reports for 2022 but
now it is scrapped and pushed back for
2023 meaning the iphone 15 and i just
have a really hard time believing that
they're going to wait that long and
still try to implement this i believe
that they wanted to make this work they
wanted to make it work earlier but at
this point they are so close to making
face id smaller for it to work better we
know that it's going to have the new
iphones are going to have hole punch
display so that whole tech is getting
miniaturized and the ultimate goal is to
be able to have it be underneath the
display and apple is also working on
that tech and i believe that that is
what's going to take over and then we
are not going to need this at all now i
do think that they still will have touch
id just not under the display technology
of course they still are going to have
budget ipads they have budget phones and
that is where having the fingerprint
sensor built into the power button makes
a whole lot of sense just like on the
ipad mini and the ipad air so hopefully
that tech will still be there and i kind
of wish that apple didn't just try to do
this on the display the hard way but
they just would have built into the
iphone's buttons um that would have been
really nice and convenient but of course
we know that they gave us the software
fix finally they could have done it a
while ago i believe but they didn't and
now since they did i believe they
decided to scrap that and just keep
moving forward with face id but you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below i want to hear
your guys's opinions go ahead and click
that circle above to subscribe to help
us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers and check out one of those
great videos right over there this has
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]